we are here in the Central Valley of
California or environmental regulations
and immigration policies are making it
very difficult for the hard-working
folks here to get by in the 1930s Dust
Bowl farmers migrated to California's
Central Valley in search of work
today the valley is one of the most
productive agricultural regions in the
United States you know the Central
Valley the valley the San Joaquin is one
of the richest valleys in the world it's
considered the breadbasket of America
85% of the jobs here in Mendota is AG
related in Fresno County alone the
agriculture industry it was a five
billion dollar industry just last year
but the farming industry on the west
side of the valley is in serious trouble
today in large part due to a fish called
the delta smelt the delta smelt is
definitely a little fish that seems to
have caused a lot of commotion up in
sacramento the delta smelt is a small
fish that is protected by the Endangered
Species Act one of the issues is that
there are pumps that pump the water down
here and those pumps also kill the delta
smelt and so you've got competing
interests between protecting the smelt
and pumping the water down here for the
past few years environmentalists
fighting to save the delta smelt have
been winning the political battle as a
result much of the water that used to be
pumped down to the west side of the San
Joaquin Valley is now allowed to flow
into the ocean being out here in the
west side you know farm work is it like
a dinosaur on the verge of extinction
due to the lack of water and Water
Resources about 70% of the normally
farmed farmland out in the west side has
been affected by the lack of water I do
to the Delta smell if you were to take a
little tour out into the west side once
upon a time you used to see green green
green farms all over out here with crops
floor
would be row crops tree fruit vines
what-have-you
now you go out to the west side you see
brown brown spots all over with it in
westerns water district area which you
know is it was surrounds Mendota it
impacted is the most these small towns
out here in the Central Valley they've
been hit hard a lot of people that are
unemployed unfortunately they were
roaming the streets people that had been
a part of family-owned businesses for
years right now presently we have a 40%
unemployment and what is not good it's
affected a lot of the businesses the
stores have taken big hits because when
they do the food giveaways the people
benefit but the but the businesses
suffer so you can't win you know why do
the feds worry about a fish then a
person that's human that consumes to
society and you know and works on the
fields contributes to the world and yet
the fish is more important I had people
from Europe ask me the same thing and
they said you know what well we come
from we'll worry about a stupid
elevation to the valley residents
suffering through these difficult
economic times the solution is simple we
have some of the most brilliant farming
our minds in the in the world in my
opinion right here in the Central Valley
so if we can reprioritize the American
people get some more to coming back down
these canals for these growers for these
generation old farmers in addition to a
government created water shortage the
folks in the Central Valley must live
with immigration laws that make little
sense in a region that is heavily
dependent on the labor of illegal
immigrants we had a major problem
roughly about four years ago the feds
all of a sudden say hey we're gonna make
an impact out there we're gonna do what
we have to be doing and it affected the
community but scared a lot of people you
know if your name was on a list that
would take you but the same time they
were taking other people and I don't
know that but taking people where the
kids are still in school which created a
major major social problem all of a
sudden there's kids are no parents I
mean this is they turn ugly you know
that the immigration policy you know
there that's it that's an issue
there that has been a broken it's been a
broken issue for a long time the
government knows exactly what this if it
wasn't for this undocumented worker he's
doing all this dirty work you know they
all realize it but the thing of it is
the farmers needed the businesses needed
in California according to federal data
there it's actually 98 percent of
farmworkers are immigrants and there's
lots of estimates in terms of what
percentage of farmworkers are illegal
immigrants but they range anywhere from
around 50 percent to as high as 90
percent you know my family's were
immigrant my friend families immigrated
here back in the 1920s before there was
water or as there was borders there was
no such thing as fences and you know
everybody in this community and
everybody that I know it migrated from
somewhere I'm one of four and I'm the
oldest and at nine years old I started
to work in the fields my daddy cut a
hole and he made it my size so I could
weed and thin cotton so we appreciate
the person who working out there in the
field because thanks to that person we
get our product cheaper they know it's a
problem but the all they come out
there's all we got to protect the fence
so we gotta protect the borders that's
how they come out with okay and it just
puts a political be is far as I'm
concerned farmers in the valley and I
imagine throughout the us tend to be
relatively conservative so you have a
lot of farmers who say you know what I'm
you know a lifelong Republican but on
this issue of illegal immigration I
really feel like we can't take a just
deport them all type stance there are a
lot of people that have helped us build
the Central Valley a lot of people that
have came from other places besides here
in America I would like to see and I
think that I probably would speak for
most people an immigration plan that
would help immunize the people that are
here so that they can be documented
citizens
contribute to our economy in the right
way making sure that that's being done
despite the problems the people we spoke
to are optimistic about the future which
shouldn't be surprising after all the
Central Valley has always attracted
self-reliant immigrants willing to work
hard to pursue their dreams I have three
children who attend UC Davis two at the
medical school and one at the regular
school I have the other two in
Sacramento
and they're on vacation out so they're
right now they're out there in the mines
it's their motivation to continue the
education one thing about the centrality
of people here in the Central Valley we
pull our bootstraps up when it's time
you have to go and try to make a living
for yourself yeah just you